we flew him all the way from boca raton
florida right to calabasas he is one of
the best welterweights on the planet
he's coming off a fight of the night
against hamza the boogeyman it's gilbert
burns on this week's food truck diaries
and i'm feeding them bbw barbecue
not what you're thinking on this week's
food truck diaries
[Music]
good to see you man my pleasure brother
friendliest man in the welterweight
division
all the way out here from boca raton
florida brother yes got that nice
sunkissed tan
you look good man
you look damn good after being in a
freaking all-out
war with hamzap man i think it was three
rounds only so that yeah i'm good yeah
right yeah you know looking back on that
fight and
you know the the reason
i you know one of the reasons you got
the fight obviously because you're a
complete monster and you're ranked what
number two at the time
you know the number two welterweight in
the world
no one to your credit nobody wanted to
fight homs on so he goes from 11 to the
number two guy in the world
and
you know there's this hype train on
hamza and you know i'm on the hype train
obviously i know you i love you you're
such a good person monster fighter but i
i was like i can't believe gilbert's
taking this fight like he has so much to
lose this guy's 11 i know the hype's
around him but it's this is an insane
fight especially only being three rounds
so
i guess walk us through the whole step
process fighting this monster nobody
else wanted to
are you glad you did it you know yeah no
no regrets and uh
the opposite was true no one wants to
fight me too so if you go up on the
ranks three four five no one wants to
fight me so
i'm 35 i'm not getting any younger yeah
you know and uh
and i have two goals only i want to
become a champion and i want to fight
the best guys whenever i'm done
i want to be that guy that i look at my
record people looking like wow that guy
for everybody so
if he's that motion he was that guy i
want to fight this guy you know i want
to fight let's see if that guy is a real
motion and
that was my reason why getting that
fight
and uh but no repeat the only repent the
fight wasn't five rounds i got it i
asked for five yeah they gave me three i
think it should kind of scramble fight a
little bit more for that i didn't was
only three rounds yep that was the only
repent but
other than that i don't regret it at all
agree when you talk about you know
you're looking back at your legacy and
your career i mean when you say you want
to fight the who you look at your resume
you've kind of done that i mean though
you said you want to be world champ and
you know
i think you'll get there but it's also
like you know you you fight kamar usman
who's a training partner there's the
narrative there is you guys train
together and
from my you know uh
perspective and listening to people who
are in the camp you know my contacts are
like hey man in training camp gilbert
whipped his ass this ain't gonna be an
easy fight so you know you get a world
title fight you rock him you know you
got him you know the most rocked he's
been in his career to be honest yeah you
know that fight doesn't go your way
but then
in the welterweight division which is
stacked it's not like the ufc did you
favors cause then it's it's freaking
wonderboy thompson you know what i'm
saying so it's like here's carol osman
uh sorry dude didn't work out here's
some wonder boy it's like goddamn but
that's but that's where you're at and
then you beat wonder boy
and then it's like here's hamzad you
know so it's like i don't know it's the
ufc it's not that they don't like you i
think they have a respect for you and
you're such a good fighter like yeah he
can beat these guys that's why you're
doing it but then you know it's it's
camaro it's you know demi maya tom dot
it's gunner nelson like you go through
your resume you have fought those guys
so you know when you go back to saying
you know when i'm when it's all said and
done i'll be that guy who fought
everybody i think you are that guy i
don't think you need to prove anything
else
but you know in in this type of
situation that you're in you know
obviously you're still one of the very
best in the world so it's kind of like
what's next for gilbert you know because
you're still
the the tip of the spear and i think
from that fight
hamza nor you lost any leverage at all
in in the queue you know to pursue a
world title i think
hamza came out with the most
you know learning experience yes meaning
you're number two in the world for a
reason and i know you're beating
everybody in training camp and you've
you know you've mopped all these guys
that you've kept you know coming to the
ufc and that's fine and dandy but these
tip of the spare guys like gilbert who
fought the who's who like this isn't
gonna be a walk in the park man and i
felt
again i think it is in his nature you
know because he's so confident and he's
so good and well-rounded when you're
walking in the octagon he's on top of
the cage like it's happy hour and i was
like oh oh what oh he thinks this is a
game dude you know
and i think he found out the hard way
you know fighting with a guy like you
man so i think he learned the most from
that i think you're always gonna
gilbert's gonna gilbert i think hamzat
has you know has to learn from that and
become better if he does want to become
world champion i believe so true i agree
100 with you i think
those type of wars
i think especially the age of the hey
he's 27 yeah he's so much to learn a lot
of experience
ups and down on the fight you know he
was wrong a couple of times
i don't know how to they don't consider
that a knock down but he was in the
knees yeah a couple times
he was hurt for sure i think he's gonna
learn so much from it but so do why i
think that's that's gonna be a good good
experience it was a good experience what
what but at your level and you're
expanding you're such an experienced
fighter which is crazy so for those that
don't know when i met gilbert he was
just the jujitsu specialist
if you guys don't know gilbert's like
one of the most
accolated
you know award-winning jiu jitsu guys
i mean in the ufc by far the pan am
world champion gold medal i can keep
this them off we'll be here for three
hours
and but here's the thing
you don't like you'll use it if you it's
there you know what i'm saying like if
i'm done took you down we would have saw
the the old you would dust off the old
ghee and bust out some tricks
but you didn't do it you're like this
striker now you're like knocking dudes
out you wobbled camaro obviously wobbled
hamza you beat wonder boy
you know you're b gunner nelson like
these guys are bad at tyrone woodley you
know what i'm saying yeah but
remember when there was 2011 or 12 i'm
not 11 dude
i i remember you you champion everybody
was coming from the
from the
the the hour bash of the year so the
world we train yeah yeah we trained
there i was only jujitsu yeah nothing i
was
because
i was starting the future
yes yes
yeah i think
and then it was uh we were vtor invites
out because he was getting ready for i
forget which fight for anthony johnson
that's right and you were there and you
were you'd only do jiu jitsu yeah and
yeah you're just this g and then you
know when they said you're getting mma
like i love that guy he's so nice man
because i know your dad and you've
always been so nice to me
and then it's like you just took off
dude you know what i'm saying it's like
you just took off man it was cool good
for you but
i even remember vitor since the
beginning so in the beginning we started
striking with vitor
and victor from the first day
you hit hard bro you still don't have
the technique but you are you gotta
believe in your boxing
and that's gonna be and then he said
that that's gonna be your difference you
can knock people out
keep trying to keep it but and then
eventually on the beginning when he said
that i didn't believe it now but
vitor belfort
telling you like man you have good
striking like you have power is like
michael jordan in the basketball be like
dude when you shoot make sure you're
gonna if he says that he knows what the
hell he's talking about but i didn't
believe back at the end he just want to
be cool yeah this and that but then
i started believing when they knocked
those guys out in training that yeah
and henry looked at me like that was a
good one like say bro but the guy's
fighting two weeks yeah yeah but then
they start happening more and then and
then i will stop believing more and then
it happened on a couple of fights but
yeah but future said it since the
beginning
i mean that just that little belief on
it from a guy like vitor belfort goes so
far i love you torment i love you he's
true he was he was at the fight oh yeah
they showed my camera yeah he's the best
yeah guys so far he's gonna be hard
so for you you know obviously
again neither you or hamza lost any
ground as far as you know hype
everything i think if anything you
earned so much more respect not that you
weren't respected before but for you to
take on this
check check check standing in the
[ __ ]
chechnyan monster this boogeyman in
chechnya that nobody wanted to take on
and you know that first round you got a
little dicey right first round a little
dicey and then second round i took over
yeah you took over and it's like
i again i think for for hamza like dude
to be the number two welterweight in the
world in the ufc which is the nfl of mma
like you didn't get there just by chance
it's not a few wins you're talking about
a career dedicated to this i think you
realize
and hopefully does because if he doesn't
which i want to talk to what's next for
both of you because if he doesn't he's
not going to beat those next guys you
can't just brawl with somebody and beat
those guys i don't think so and i matter
of fact i'll go on record and say this
if you two had a rematch in his five
rounds he thought the same way he
doesn't beat you i think if he shows up
that same hanzo yeah his for his next
fight whether chew kobe muhammad
he doesn't beat him but i i do think he
learns from it and he does
grow from it i hope so he got good team
good good you know good coaches
very young
but the eagle was there you know i could
feel that i hurt his ego a little bit
like yeah yeah i
did you feel disrespect going to this
fight
a little bit but to be honest
you don't bother me no way i just don't
want to i you don't listen to it no no
no and i knew
at that moment i i i like where you
gonna take me down we're gonna grab her
if he does take me down if he's if he's
on the feet okay he's a little bigger
he's he has more reach yeah but i'm i
knew i'm going to connect him he's going
to feel like yeah even
a two days before on thursday night we
were cutting away and i saw him in the
hallway say show me power and say bro
i'm gonna show you yeah and then he was
holding my hand show me
saturday i will show you and then
whenever the fight was over he came at
me he was broke i respect you and say
bro you want me to show your power and
show you yeah you saw it and then he
said yeah and then i say two more rounds
right now and then he that's when he
pushed me like no laughing but uh
i think we all do respect he gonna grow
so much i'm gonna grow so much
i don't i think it's gonna be a trick
he's the last step i don't i just have a
philly
kobe not gonna i i don't think coley
hamza that's next on abc like dana said
he's supposed to be i think that that's
the next step if if i'm the promoter
that's that's the fight that will make
you too i just don't think kobe been
accepted i see i and you tell me your
opinion on this i think and you know
chael's close with kobe i was talking to
chill
you know he he doesn't think he's going
to happen because of contractual issues
because kobe wants the same pay as like
a mozville or those big boys and the ufc
i i don't know where they're at i hope
he gets paid a whole bull again
so but i don't know if the ufc is going
to figure that out in time for that abc
card
so i you know i see i don't do you think
it's a case of kobe going i'm good man i
don't fight that guy because if i'm
colby or camaro after watching you fight
him
making him look human where he's never
looked human before i'm going oh yeah
i'm down five rounds i'll do that
i'll do that yeah i think i think that
would help those guys out for sure
before that no one was asking for these
fights now everybody oh i'll fight him
but
uh
i i think kobe is a little messed up
from the circuit punch i think really
yeah that too in the whole thing
i don't think he'll be ready for july if
he's he's going to be a fight i think he
want to get paid a little bit more i
don't know i just that's my guess i
don't think he's going to fight
and i i live on the table say if you
guys want to go five rounds let's do it
again run it back we do it again right
now man i don't think it's going to
happen but
yeah you might be right maybe kobe does
is it next for hamza maybe you're not
next mid ufc wants something else for
you you know i think for hamzad if it's
not colby it's probably uh muhammad
she's coming off a big win over vicente
luke
hello brazilian i just yeah i just think
every match you i think people would
watch there 100 you know it kind of i
understand doesn't make sense here right
now for him it doesn't make sense but on
the side on
for the it didn't make sense before for
me you know i agree you did him a solid
so but you know you know this game we'll
see he's not going to be like i i just
him he's like
yeah yeah that was a good fight i wanted
thank god but i don't think they're like
yeah let's run it back because yeah
clearly you're a monster
so if it's not hanzo do you have any i i
have a lease right i know you have a
list and tell me if i'm right about this
list i know you i know dustin poirier
who you know dustin was like if if it's
a big fight i'm down to do it you know
i'll go to welterweight or whatever they
want to do
so dustin poirier that's a fun one yeah
that that's a fun way and i freaking
love dusty he said that the the the
sauce and everything i like
my kids love him kids always take a
picture with him he's one of the best
people i like it very good guy uh but
he's on the list you know i give me this
yes i went with the ufc we have a
meeting with dana we hunted with a good
one when was this meeting there was a
friday before muhammad and
that was on that friday so last friday
okay so after the after the fight
and it went good did it i think it's
going to be a big fight nasty and uh how
could it not
yeah yeah so what was your what was the
list my lisey's
mate nick yeah that's the number one
they match though they poor year i threw
everybody in that list and i put connor
in the list
i put kobe on that list so i'll take my
money for anything any any of these
fights right so me too and
so that's the least but
i'm still fighting any wife if knowing
this least is available if nick not
ready nate i know he isn't disgusting
trying to get out of this country four
year maybe get a 55 fight
uh
i don't know if those guys are not
already kobe funny hamza whatever then
i'll fight below you know but yeah it's
not my
it's not my first option but
uh i'll fight anyone you're down no yeah
yeah sure i think it's a good list man
and hopefully coming off that and you
know you got performance of the night
you and hamza both got performance
tonight you know again i think it built
both of your guys profile and obviously
the ufc is excited about it if you met
with him like yeah man let's figure it
out you know and there's so many bonuses
too at least you get the win
rich rich so usually i pay for a food
truck but maybe you'll pay today i'll
pay him no i'm just kidding i got you
man let me feed you some barbecue
because hopefully they don't give you a
late notice fight and then you miss
weight because of my
i can make i'm making two
two weeks two times two weeks call me
the title was one month so so you know
what you're doing i know
we have a barbecue today you're a fan of
barbecue let's do it let me feed you i'm
out here grinding every day i'm really
trying to get it i take the ellen
elevate i push it past the limit don't
need no diamonds on my wrist oh god
because i swear the vision big just like
the thick boy squad
let's take a little break from chatting
with my brother from pretty far away in
brazil we're talking about gilbert burns
let's take a little break because
man the world is back the world is open
and you're trying to go back to your old
workout classes and they're filled up
man they're filled up it's easy to just
get bumped out of your workout class
what if i told you there was a bike with
a tv on it and you can get your workout
in at home with world-class trainers
it's so much fun i'm talking about
peloton your boy's been a member for six
freaking years it's going to keep you
motivated 24 7. all right 24 7. whatever
fitness level you're at peloton
instructors don't just teach they
motivate you to get your buns moving if
you're thick you want to get slimmer we
got you covered man pelton fits so easy
into your life if you're looking for a
10 minute upper body stretch between
your calls at work you're working from
home maybe you want a 40 minute run
before bed whatever you're trying to do
peloton got you covered man right now is
the perfect time to try out peloton i
keep telling you guys peloton is the new
wave pelton bike plus is now 500
buckaroos less it's best price yet
including free delivery and setup and
there are
more game changing prices available on
the original pelton bike which i have
and the peloton tread that's their
treadmill right pelton tread you know
this visit onepeloton.com to learn more
that's visit one peloton dot com to
learn more peloton
how you doing my man appreciate you
doing this uh anything you recommend
everything looks good uh
if you like uh bbws you can get the bbw
to grilled cheese or macaroni or
whatever meat you want or some loaded
fries trying to [ __ ] your pants yeah
sandwiches
um
i mean what are you thinking gilbert i
think you know that that sandwich with
the
mac and cheese oh i like your style dude
yeah
yeah
i'll and i'll do the uh i'll do the hot
link with the brisket
thank you sir
gotta get tick
we're about to be thinking i mean you're
for welterweight you'd
think with two c's i'm trying to get you
to three in my man
you eat that thing you're you're
officially three c's man he's doing yeah
[Music]
[Music]
we give you [ __ ] boy
we still gotta give it up
let me tell you about the thick boy
right around the city making big noise
small city kid in a big town
first name brandon friends calling big
brown like drake on one thousand said it
is it's hard to find somebody that's
better than big brown pound for pound
right around town can't believe what i
found
brandon shop big boy mom
tall silky buttery corner cop
definitely the man for the job cause cte
can't stop my dog
[Music]
let's take a little break here on the
food truck dives with gilbert burns
because man paying down debt can be
stressful especially when you need to
keep track of multiple monthly payment
dates if you're tired of juggling all
these due dates all right you need to
get it down to one easy payment all
right that's what you got to do man that
way you'll just have one due date a
month no more stress no more hassle
credit karma can help you find the best
option for you talk about credit karma
baby credit karma uses your credit data
to find loan offers that are
personalized just for you so you can
have a better idea of what loan amount
you can get approved for credit karma
will even show you your chances of
approval so you can choose between loan
offers that you're more likely to get
approved for and apply with more
confidence we gotcha man comparing loan
offers on credit karma is 100 free won't
affect your credit score and you could
save money credit karma apply with more
confidence today are you ready to apply
great head to credit karma.com loan
offers to see your personalized offer
right now go to creditkarma.com
loanoffers to find the loan perfect for
you that's creditkarma.com loan offers
now let's get back to the food truck
diaries all right mr burns you got that
bbw my man you go down
it's uh it's everything's heavy here
but i got uh
i got the hot link
are there good luck eating that thing
you're not making a mess that's why we
got napkins that's good
there's good food out by you
smoker
lot of brazilian food brazilian state
house a lot of cuban food yeah that
makes sense a lot but it's not it's not
like like la like you know i think some
people have never been to l.a like food
trucks there's a show with food trucks
food trucks out here like legit somebody
they have they have that food truck like
yeah very very good
they're food trucks in brazil
yeah they're food i mean there's a lot
of i know i act like it's freaking 1972
but
i went to brazil
i got knocked out by a friend no
guerrilla so that's cool but i went to
brazil and i remember loving him by the
way but um
i went to brazil horrible time for me
i'll never forget it but um
at the on the corners
i remember like the food trucks were
like acai bowls but different than acai
here in america you tell me if i'm off
on this because acai in like brazil was
like healthy here it's it's purple ice
cream
like americans got them we messed it up
let's write yourself that
they have both they have in brazil they
have the the
the kind of the fit one is a little bit
more healthy actual acai berry yeah they
have but they have couples that just
like here like
that's purple ice cream i think vanilla
and just diet purple but they got a
couple guys in florida i think because
of the community so big right there that
they have a legit acai florida yeah two
three places like legit
yeah i think it's because the acai bear
is like so expensive so they're trying
to figure out something very expensive
so they bring but
it's like a smoothie or it's just like a
nice grain yeah and it's a mix no when i
was out there
some brazilians like actual local
brazilians got me like real outside you
can't find that in l.a very good right
so good very good not like really sweet
but i felt good too yeah it's a good end
it's kind of like
he's compared with the fed with avocado
he's a good fan for sure if you take a
big bow it's freaking too much but if
you get a small bow yeah it's good
energy yeah i remember uh vitor bell for
his dad there's a running theme of vitor
belfort on this but uh
yeah he made his call in belfort belfort
yeah yeah and he wore wears sunga
everywhere
he's humbling beach volleyball
he's still doing the same thing yeah and
he's like really tanked because he was
out in the sun right
he's so tan and then he's like you boys
want to play and i was like i guess and
he beat the [ __ ] out of us and all this
very good i came in like two dime pieces
and thongs and he's in just a purple
sungla the whole time
people didn't know him he's that wire
he's still triggering today crazy like
game blouses like just was like get the
[ __ ] out of here but he was great uh
shout out to brazil do you go back to
brazil much i go every year sometimes to
ice i'm planning to go now with the
family
my mom is just getting graduated now and
nurses she's 64 but so beside it decided
uh the pops of the states i'm trying my
grandpa to watch the kiddos
yes that is the best but they want to
decline my mother-in-law visa and i'm
getting the process now july they get a
visa but it's not easy they're declining
everyone in brazil like the consulate
was closed for almost two weeks because
you called it
i think they're trying to bank in a
little bit for those for sure but also
just go through the border because
everyone's doing that now yeah right
illegally but we'll figure out thanks
buddy
just kidding uh you had the content yeah
yeah yeah yeah i got the contact i'll
make it happen dude but uh
yeah
so i was obviously in your big name in
the united states and everyone knows who
you are and you just had that big fight
you know pay-per-view and all that
but i would assume in brazil you're like
you're tom cruise in brazil especially
in the hometown am i right because
before you answer
when especially when i was fighting
even about five years ago like
brazilians were the face of the ufc if
you go you know you're talking about
silva jose aldo big nog great right hand
again we'll go back to that uh big nog
you had gonzaga do you know uh dos
santos
you know uh javier dos anjos yes like
you when you look at all these brazilian
monsters men
and then now
there's not as many is that fair to say
not like what do you think that is yeah
i think it's changing the generation
most of these guys are very retired
peter big nog
all those guys kind of retired and i was
the next generation charles oliver
glover to share still there
but now it's kind of like me paulo costa
you know the new generation but aldo is
always there you know although he's the
king of rio rancho i know he's never
leave yeah
freaking good but also it's not fair to
say that brazil fell off i'm just saying
they're not as dominant as they were but
to your point you know you still got
glover texaire who's world champion and
then you've got charles oliveira who's
champion it's also championship white
boy you know amanda i'm in the nunez
that's right yeah we got a couple guys
and we got me right there we got a
couple guys right there pedro moon yours
got me luca 170
we got those hundreds at 55 the top five
from now wrong yeah we got we have guys
in there just
i think just the momentum that means you
get good momentum you get a lot of
champions but he changed you know you
got a couple russians chewy guys
they're common man you know you gotta
prepare for that yeah
you know everything goes through phases
you know but i
i remember when i was in brazil like
that culture
like
the ufc fighters in the states
you know they're if you're like
world champion especially before jon
jones crazy antics but when he was john
jones
you know he had like a nike spawn ship
and he was at the espn award and stuff
like that and he was looked at you know
equivalent to like a lebron or you know
uh patrick mahomes i feel like now it's
not the case i don't i don't know what
that is but that's in america in brazil
you guys the the ufc fighters they're
like josiado noguera's basic you know
again when i fought no garen brazil
that's like fighting michael jordan
like nobody's rooting for it i didn't
know that it was a nightmare yeah i
regret it but the thing is is about like
in brazil like you guys are
your gods out there man i didn't realize
how big of a deal it is
is that is
even for the ufc the second biggest
market you know for sure the u.s and in
brazil
and people
people love fighting right now those are
two things the soccer number one by by
far
and then fighting coming acts and
everybody fights and to be honest i was
kind of talking to the ufc and seeing
they sell a lot in brazil the paper
version sell a lot but
still a lot of scams in brazil like a
lot of what it's cams to watch it they
have all those linking
like illegal downloads and stuff so
i was even trying to get a little bit
into that and make sure they do the the
ufc fight pass in brazil i think that's
the way they're gonna
change this help out i think the numbers
don't don't don't match yeah like maybe
they sell a million paper views a
million it's not a paper group but it's
a membership
but i think the real number is like
20 million is 25 million and they lose a
lot of money so
kind of touching to that on the meeting
that we had but
the numbers in brazil can get crazy yeah
and i assume right now
jose aldo aldo's still the king of rio
yeah like he's huge he's here for
shakespeare i don't compare i think me
not even me but like let's put amanda
glover
and uh and charles they're not even that
big
compared to
anderson was just on a different level
oh my god vitor whenever i was growing
up they have the first big brother
brazil and they make it they make a
similar one another in another channel
and vito was there vito was there with
his wife sucks
right there wasn't even they were they
kind of they had a relationship they
were off and in the in the in the
reality show they went back yeah but
they were huge so back in the days vito
was
yeah movie like everywhere in brazil
vito was bigger than anyone see i think
that's what's cool about brazil it's
great you guys have so much respect for
these fighters and it's such a tough job
in america we kind of take it for
granted like even look at like boxing
like deontay wilder was world champion
for a long time couldn't really sell out
like maybe sell out a small arena in
alabama he's not selling out like mass
square garden or some of these other
stuff where if he was brazilian in
brazil crazy
you were there you saw it in the whole
arena not so stupid
the the energy to go away event in
brazil is just different
yeah whenever you go there prelims that
she just sold
here i mean people should think it's
cool to show up you know yeah halfway
through the main card yeah
four prelims they started pretty much
it's loud like crazy people people love
that in brazil he's the culture you know
a lot of fighters
a lot of boxes a lot of football it's
kind of like the same
even football if you go towards just a
soccer
in brazil
just it's gonna be loud yeah yeah yeah
and and i think the culture cheer like
the the a lot of people are very poor
and and that's when they they gather
energy that's that's the motivation
that's one thing that comes with the
thing that people everyone comes to and
also like a lot of you know jose aldo
and some of those guys came from those
favelas and stuff so they represent them
so yeah they it it's real yeah and it's
a is it
i think it's
i don't know he's an example free that
guy came i can do with you so he gave us
a lot of fights yeah if he that guy's
there he came okay you know like yeah i
think nothing is that cute yeah it's
cool it's really dumb hopefully they let
you headline up a fight in brazil
i hope i hope they come they that event
me and how's that supposed to be in
brazil on the may 7
6 that's going on in phoenix right now
that is always in brazil oh really but
they had the arena
i think because the kovit and the other
thing that came from kovitt and then in
brazil are very big brazil's
still heard from the world cup uh where
from the world cup they were hurt and
then with the coffee
the brazil is not a good place right now
so
it's kind of the fighting coming back
but
i i believe next year maybe they say end
of the year they can go they could go to
brazil but i believe next year for sure
one headline would you wait till the end
of the year to fight if it was in brazil
they said hey we'll give you a fight in
albuquerque in two months or you can
wait till the end of the year wait that
long then the year you find brazil you
don't you wait in brazil
that's a tough question brother howard
tries to take both but you ever been to
albuquerque
i never beat to albuquerque trust me man
no wait for brazil wait oh okay no
shadow in albuquerque oh wait okay yeah
you should wait man
yes i guess for you man really it's
you know with the division and all these
monsters and there's contracts it's kind
of out of your hands i like i like your
uh for like a better term your hit list
and if you got anybody on that list
you know we're going sizzler dude we're
go we're buying all the real acai in
brazil you know if you get one of those
names like it's on man
that's what i'm looking for next uh
so we talk about it they're gonna give
me a new contract on my next fight and
i'm excited about that but
i wanted one of these names you know
yeah you know what you deserve it thank
you right
you did some assault with homs that no
one else wanted to fight him for a
reason
it wasn't even
to be honest it wasn't evie for that i
just wanna i'm i'm a fighter and then i
like i said i'm at the end i'm not on
the beginning of my career you want to
get i don't know i might have
between three i don't i just don't see
my fight fighting in your 40s no i don't
see it in your 40s yeah i don't want to
fight at 40s and then i i got kids it
might happen but i don't want it you
know don't saying never but yeah
but i'm 35 turning 36 this year i think
you get a good three years and almost
three years ago nine fights dude you're
left on this three years i wanna fight
everybody like i don't wanna you know i
wanna get going let's go i want to get a
good momentum good and and fight all
these emotions whenever i'm done
i really want to look at like wow you
know you keep saying i mean you're doing
it man but i want to make it through
your resume
i want to make it more like are you
brazilians man you're looking josiah
rda's rda is a he's the you know he has
the hard yeah dude
everybody
everybody ever ever wow hall of famer
also i know i keep talking about brazil
but whatever when i was there
you know i was the outcast and i'm
fighting no garrett he's beloved man i
was the favorite in the fight so nobody
want to do me any favors so i was told
hey just don't eat random food like make
sure you're smart about it because who
knows what they're gonna do with the
food so i didn't know where to go and
rda picked me up we've never met our day
would pick me up in his car and he has
kids he's busy scheduled
even outside his training would pick me
up i would train at gordos he'd pick me
up take me to places like you can trust
this place give me food
like just made sure i was good to go man
yeah he was such a good musician he's a
great guy yeah he's a very great guy i
love
i don't know if i see i don't know if
he's here if he's in brazil yeah even
texan i don't know but he's a great guy
he's a guy that like hey you know the
crazy thing
we're in the same school
you know who was his best friend
my older brother oh really for like
years old he was close oh that's cool
same hometown same place i could have
walked to his this place and he my
brother and that's why that's how came
the nickname the ring my brother was
total so i was a little tough
my older brother was the very toughest
freaking navy still known in brazil
he was
rda best friend they still touch you
that's really cool yeah crazy how crazy
and both became a ufc fighter yeah
crazy ufc not just a ufc fighter you
know you're one of the top guys he he
was a world champion
who would have thought before 170.
brazilians are kind of like canadians
i've never met a mean brazilian
apollo field was mean to me but that's
the only one was yeah and i think there
was some mental issues there but it was
after i lost he was talking [ __ ] to me i
don't know in the locker room i'm like
what is happening right now yeah but i
think that's a mental issue but out take
him out of the equation brazilians in
general like canadians i've never met a
mean canadian either you guys are so
friendly you're good and you're so you
guys are so goddamn tough
yeah i think
you gotta to make in brazil you gotta be
a little tough
i went to these favelas too man yeah you
went you were in there yeah i went there
yeah and i brought geared to all the
kids they love it right how they treat
you they're like oh dude
one of the best experiences i've ever
had in my life like went to favela
they were doing jiu jitsu on uh dirt
yeah yeah i'm talking like 40 kids and
like what and that's the time i had to
sponsor with echo i figured and maybe
sentry gear or whatever so i called like
hey you guys need to send gear to this
freaking place i'll be out here in four
weeks cause i was there for press and i
was fighting four weeks later and they
were like all right we got it they sent
all this gear so i flew into brazil on
that tuesday and all the gear uh they
had the hotel so we drove it in there
and when you go in the favela you can't
just go in like there's dudes it's ran
by you know yeah yeah you know you eat
stuff some dark arts yeah and they have
the ak-47s but because they knew you
know i was on all the tvs out there and
stuff like that they're like oh you're
good man
treated me great and then you brought
the kids gear and god did these kids
they were so happy and they had nothing
to do i'm i'm doing a project there in
rio now just to do free jiu-jitsu so i
have guys from santa boothe supporting
they're going to sponsor the party that
everything's going to be cool but
my wife bruno
she i i was not in the favela was super
close but not in the favela very i could
walk like like i woke a couple of meters
off being a favela
is in the she's from there yeah so
whenever
i go to i go to brazil i go see her mom
and whenever i start going then you got
to go all the way up
on the middle is all the drug dealers
are yeah and
he is constantly changing because those
guys are they going to die or they go to
jail
or another guy comes and take over so
he's constantly changing
every time that i go to brazil i gotta
rent a car i don't have a car in brazil
when they come in
and the way to go up
if it's at night you turn the lights off
and you put the lights inside your car
on so they see who's coming oh wow and
the doors the the the the windows got to
be open so every time that they come me
everybody's looking at me like
and do they know then they know you you
change it so you change it so it's not
like you're like no hey larry he's like
no larry he's always
sometimes couple guys to see my
mother-in-law
come to us though yeah no whenever they
go
and everybody looking at me and they say
what's up what's up a couple guys what
the [ __ ] and then
i go there and sometimes i gotta go
grocery store will never come down say
hey stop here come here yeah and then
take a picture then what's up you got
any any ufc gear that i always have
that's cool
you guys don't recognize me i was scared
no no don't be scared you always saying
you know here's the thing about those
favelas you know how like in uh it's
it's backwards in l.a so in la you know
how like the most expensive houses are
in the hills
well in uh the favela it's different
the the the worst like ghettos parts are
in the hills
you gotta go up all the way up on the
mountain great views yeah ocean views
best views but yeah
right the best views it comes at a price
though you turn your lights off and reel
down the window
and if you don't turn your lights on
they stop you so
first time when i was dating with my
girlfriend when they came up
they stopped it hey where you going you
know when bruno's house how are you and
then
down everybody stopped but
i mean you know what a great little
rough don't you see your girl you go
through all these steps hopefully
something is worth that you got two
beautiful kids
she's number one support she's a she's a
beast too
she's a black belt
national champion a couple times she
fought
mma amateur before me before no hershey
she had a woman just a real battle she
can fight yeah
yeah crazy right now a lot of enemies
this is the difference from me and you
you're such a badass you you were
showing to your girl you went through
all that favela hassle dude rihanna
could be those favelas i'm like i'm out
no i'm not let me know when she comes
down the mountain
who i was with was worried but i was
good this is a different level there
yeah but before i get you out here dude
um i just want your picks on some of
these big fights so let's say
hamzat and kobe fight on abc let's say
it happens in some weird world there's a
small chance who do you have in that
fight [ __ ] there's a very close fight
it's a good fight right very close i
think uh hamza might have a little bit
more power in the hands that's fair got
a couple of knockouts he meet what about
what about the pressure and the
wrestling of colby
because if coach we can get him down to
the long run
wrestling i know he's very long
i think
i don't know i it's close
i don't know i might give two hums out
i think if hamza learns from your fight
and correct i think he will i i i yeah
second round right
i i was pressuring that guy was coming
forward and then
i robbed him hard he was on his knee he
took me down
i did a couple elbows
time was over that freaking that was not
with me i pushed him i can't [ __ ] away
from me if i was over and then he's
smacking me a little b and then i was up
and i went to my corner
and a lot of cameras a lot of guys in
front of me you say get out of the way
let me see this guy then always look bro
he was that you could tell in his eyes
yeah that's like dead he run the rematch
he's four or five and he's coach
that guy was having a heart attack
because he was at the same time i was
listening to harry tate was kind of
cleaning me up that that i have a big
cut right here
and i was listening you listen to me
yeah i'm listening here i'm just going
to look at these guys you want to check
it and they say i want you to do this
yeah
and then look no he's
his coach
all right
if i had two more rounds yeah i'm going
to kill this guy but the guy's going to
die at you in the heart this guy's going
to make it for him
but yeah but
so i guess he's going to learn from that
and i think i think he can fight smarter
i think he can be cool yeah it's such a
good fight and then in the championship
fight with kamar usman and leon edwards
that's close people
i'm telling i'm telling that right now
the orlando is very underrated people
which is so like how long are we gonna
have no idea that guy's very good he's
so cute just think about it a striker
long and southpaw that's already oh [ __ ]
that's already tough problems
and that guy has a great team and i
watch this team they they very
underrated people don't talk about it
but they got arnold ollie arnold allen
yeah
fracking good a lot of guys jay herbert
a lot of guys they're looking like man
that team is solid yeah people don't
give a lot of a lot of credit for him
but he's very dave you know tomorrow
pretty well though you think and i know
but that's why it's going to be closed i
agree that it's going to be close and i
think
if i got those three guys me my opinion
kobe hamza
and uh and liam leon has the best chance
oh to beat to be
uzman i think because
he's a striker he can grapple he can
yeah very long
these are the guys they are wrestlers
yeah they can strike don't get me wrong
they're both guys inside yeah but they
are wrestlers yep that guy's a striker i
think
on the street guys i think liam get
get more chance to become more and i
think the fight is going to be closer if
kamar kamal is very smart yeah he's been
there a couple of times i think he can
find i think he's going to take the
fight very seriously
but if he don't
he's a mistake
he's a rematch you know now fighting for
the time that i'd be
waiting for the opportunity i agree if i
was giving to him when they offered to
me he said no four reasons yeah no i
need a proper campaign now he's having
so it's a great fight and then last
night your teammate who who's fighting
uh soon would be uh michael chandler yes
freaking guy my dad tony ferguson my get
he might i love my i love my he's my
best he might get my fight of the year
with ferguson yes it's a great fight and
that guy loves to go to war
and like i mean i like to go to war but
i'd rather kill you then go to a war
right if i have a chance to give give me
your knack your arm your chain first run
i'll take it i'll take it whatever yeah
my channel is you but
he loves to be in the war
it's like when you find gaichi before
we're talking
of course dude i know i got them like
you know get him to get his guard up and
then blast double man see how good
he goes that was the plan i got in there
and then i just
yeah he's like then it was like
he flipped the switch then he goes crazy
i just
i michael's gonna win that that that's
i'm putting money on he's gonna win for
sure yeah he hits too hard you can't
play that game with jim no no but
i don't think he's gonna be
i think it's going to be a war that
might beat my fight like yeah i mean
tony has not quitted him no no no savage
michael has a lot of power bro all the
power i knew i think he can i
saw a couple guys 40 on the match
multiple times with michael he
he has a powerful he's a beast not a
small guy but he's a 55 but he's not big
you saw he's short yeah he's short but
he's like short thick
on the right hand that if connect good
knife i i know how tough he is but good
night but i just
guy loves to be on the fire i think it's
going to be crazy i'll be there i'll be
there to support michael well as much as
i'm excited for leon camaro hamzak colby
i'm more excited to see what's next for
you man this is great i hope it happens
before you get out of here which thank
you for coming dude my pleasure i mean
they say wonder boy is the nicest guy
dude i think you got him beat and i've
always said i beat him i think not only
did you beat him inside the octagon but
in friendliness as well i'm sorry wonder
boy also wonder man though right he's
40. so
bmf yeah there you go you beat him man
so we always give out a shoe here to the
the fighters that come that represent
you i don't know if you're a sneaker guy
you were in the rocks uh ufc issued one
so hopefully these are cooler uh these
are the jordan four
uh the lightnings for you wow you know
what a little throwback to brazil the
yellow i when i think y'all i think
brazil dude so these are for you my man
these are my boys at suplex in philly
which i will see in may so shout out to
the shots
our boys sent these man but wow these
are for you thanks for doing the show
brother we wish you nothing but the best
hopefully these make your kids jealous
now caveat with these don't wear these
in the favela right
i don't want to be responsible for you
getting jacked i think you're all right
okay i can't yeah okay yeah josie aldo's
not on the first day no first day second
day second one in the second day but
these are for you brother look at jason
jason look at the shoes yeah he's a
sneaker guy good man wow thank you so
much i appreciate it appreciate you man
give it burns everybody
[Music]
[Music]
you ready